all right you've done well if you've
been holding on so far
as you can you can see what i mean now
by why this is like the tour de france
is long but it is also it also has these
these tough conceptual climbs you have
to get through
uh we're not done yet we have the final
section to do the final part
part c says use the product of these six
roots
to deduce that cos plan 12 um
cos 5.12 equals a quarter
where does this come from okay now um
there are two
final pieces of the puzzle that we need
um to have in our minds in order to
solve
this particular question and the first
one has to do with
what they say right at the beginning
right it's use the product of these
six roots so they're trying to call to
mind our understanding of
polynomials from earlier in the year
particularly
our understandings of roots and
coefficients
now because it's probably been a while
since you've looked at these
i'm going to try and refresh your memory
we noticed that there was
for any polynomial equation we started
off with like quadratics and stuff like
that because it was easy
there was a relationship between the
roots and the coefficients
even if you didn't know what the roots
were
for example if you wanted to find out um
what would happen if you added the roots
of
a quadratic equation you could work that
out by just
going straight to the coefficients of
said quadratic and just evaluating
minus b on a right and there's a couple
ways to prove that you could prove it
using
the quadratic formula or by completing a
square or quadratic identities bunch of
different ways but this is a result that
we showed right
if by contrast and with um with
quadrants we would call it the
product of roots if you wanted to know
what happens when you multiplied your
roots
even when you don't know what the roots
are you can just go straight to the
coefficients and you would take c on a
provided you had um you know your
quadratic written
in this form now within the extension
one course what we do
is we expand on that result this is
what's true for quadratics
but actually these results which are
also called viete's results because
that's the name of the mathematician who
kind of codified all this for us
these results that relate roots
and their coefficients generalize for
polynomials they're true for all
polynomials of any degree
so if you for example went from a
quadratic to a
cubic if you still have these
coefficients in like descending order
for your powers of
x then you could say minus b on a is
still equal to something with the roots
it's
um going to be three roots though so
it'll be alpha plus beta plus gamma
right and then when you went to the next
uh
next coefficient over you got the
alpha plus beta alpha uh sorry alpha
times beta
alpha times gamma and then beta times
gamma right
now for this reason um i think there is
a more helpful way
to say what we're talking about here
rather than sum and product
summon product is kind of um it makes
more sense when you're talking about
quadratics like this
but the way i think about it is that
these are actually all sums of roots
it's just that we take different amounts
of roots at the same
time so this is the sum this first
column here
is the sum of the roots one at a time
you can see here you just take here's
one root here's the other
here's one root and then another and
then another i'm doing them individually
when you have a look over the next
column this one it's still the sum of
roots but instead of doing them one at a
time i'm doing them two at a time
i'm pairing them and i'm getting every
possible pairing that i can now
for a quadratic because there's only two
there's only one pair
but when you go to a cubic there are
three roots so you can pair them up in
three different ways
when you go to the next one when you've
got a delta you've got even more
combinations
and when you have a look this this sort
of helps us to explain
what's going on when you go to the next
result right
alpha beta gamma is the result of dating
them
three at a time right and of course we
just go over to the next coefficient in
this case it would be
d over here and the signs you might
recall they flip
uh minus uh sorry plus minus plus
what i did it backwards minus plus minus
and then plus minus plus etc
now the reason why i highlight that that
sign flipping back and forth is
important to us is because
i don't have a quadratic or a cubic in
this question
i have got a polynomial of degree
6 right so i'm gonna need to go not just
to minus b on a c on a or minus d
on a to get the product of the roots six
at a time i'm going to have to go
several steps over
right if i want them four not four not
five
but six at a time i'm just going to
follow this pattern so
you can see it's going to go negative
positive negative the next one will be
positive and then it'll be e over a then
it'll be
back to negative minus f over a and then
g over a because a
polynomial of degree 6 will have those
seven coefficients a b d c
d e f g okay now
this is the result that i'm interested
in it's the product of these
sick roots all in one hit so i need to
look carefully at what g
and a are actually equal to now when you
have a look at the polynomial that's
been provided to us
the coefficient attached to the highest
power
in your polynomial that's that's a you
have to be careful though because
what you're doing to get to b it's the
next power down but there is no x to the
power of 5
term in this polynomial so in this case
b would be 0. the next one you're going
to get is c that would be negative 48.
you skip d because well you don't skip d
but d is equal to 0 because there is no
x cubed term and so you can see i'm
going to go ac
and then e and then g is the last one
it's going to
be um this negative one right on the end
here
okay so um that was my revision of
polynomial roots and coefficients let's
bring that back to the question that i'm
interested in i can say
4a sixth degree polynomial
i'm going to quote this one of viet's
results i'm going to say
the product of the roots which in this
case
i actually know what the roots are
they're um cos pine 12 cos
3.12 and so on right i'm so i'm going to
write that
cos pi on 12 cos 3 pi on 12.
um this time i'm going to write them all
you'll see why in a second
cause 7 by on 12 cos
9 pi and 12 and then lastly cos 11 pi
on 12. so this is my sum of roots six at
a time
they're all there what's that equal to
it's g over
a which in this case we just said
there's g
and i should have highlighted a as well
a is 32
okay so i'm going to get on the right
hand side of my equation
minus 1 that's g over 32.
that's a okay now
there was a lot to get there but um i
now have you know i've solved one
problem and i've created another one
right
um i have this relationship that
includes cospan 12 and cos 5 pi on 12
and there they are right there and there
except i also have
all this other fluff flying around right
you're kind of like
uh what am i supposed to do with now
i'll stay with this color
what am i supposed to do with this cause
3 pi on 12. that that doesn't appear
in in this result here um for that
matter what am i supposed to do with
everything trailing on the end
cos 7 pi and 12 cos 9 pi on 12 cause 11
pound 12
none of them appear in this equation so
somehow i'm obviously going to have to
get rid of them um and
it's probably helpful that i know i'm
supposed to get rid of them because
when you have a look at the right hand
side um it's not equal to what i want
either right it's minus 1 on 32.
i'm supposed to get a quarter and i'm
supposed to be positive right
so how do i deal with this okay again
another conceptual
chunk that you need to call your mind
back to we've already used
trigonometric identities in this
question earlier on uh in part one
we had to use the pythagorean identity a
number of times like this
when you have a look at what we've got
here i'm going to need to pull on
another trigonometric identity but i
don't have any sine squareds i need to
get rid of
i have a whole bunch of cosines i need
to get rid of which
trigonometric identity that we have
access to will help me get rid of
a product because they're all multiplied
right a product of
different cosines well if you are
struggling to
remember luckily for you we have a
reference sheet
and if you have a look to the page that
has all the trigonometric identities on
page 2
you will see there are a couple of
candidates but one that is better than
the others
but there's a couple of candidates here
for getting rid of or
re-sort of rephrasing cosines when
you've got a multiple
a multiple set of them and they're all
multiplied together okay
you can see here there is cos a plus b
it's got
cos a cos b sort of tucked inside it
right
that's the product of two cosines that
looks promising right
but you can go one better if you scroll
further down you can see
right here you've got cos a cos b which
is exactly what you want no sign a sine
b coming along for the right
and it's in term or in the terms of
other cosines here on the right hand
side
okay so what i can do is i can use that
identity cos a cos b
equals half of there's a sum and a
difference of different angles in there
i can use this result in fact i've
already sort of grabbed it so i'm going
to insert it right now
it should be here i can use this result
in order to simplify this this garbled
mess um
so long as i can choose appropriate
values
for a and for b because because this
identity is true
for for any a any angle a and any angle
b but i don't just have random
angles i have specific ones okay so
i want you to think about this right in
fact um if you are at this point you're
like oh i wonder what to do next i would
encourage you to pause the video after i
give you this instruction and see if you
can work this out yourself
i need to choose my amib appropriately
and i have four angles to choose from
right i've got three pi and twelve
seven pound twelve nine point twelve and
eleven pi twelve i've gotta get rid of
them
but there are many ways to pair up these
four
angles and not all of them are equally
useful so
i want you to have a think for a moment
about pause the video and think
what might be the most useful pairings
of these angles
try some pairings and see do they end up
with something useful or do they end up
with something where you're like oh
well that's no help it doesn't get me
any closer to the answer right
pause the video have a think
[Music]
and for now if you are either you know
content to just
plow through or if you've gone away and
come back and like i think i have an
answer right
let me guide you through my thought
process of how this works right
cos three pi and twelve right if i have
a look at this one which is the best
angle to pair it with well if i don't
know any better let's just try any
random angle right suppose i just pair
it with the next one
two pine 12 7 pi on 12. if i pair them
together
and i said um i'm going to say cos 3 pi
12 here
cos 7 pi 12 here what do i get on the
right hand side well if you do
the difference here let's just do beaker
take away smaller that's easier
you get 7 pound 12 take away 3 pi and 12
7 12 take away 3.12 that's
4 pi on 12 which i can simplify to pound
three
now that's promising because cos of pi
on three that's what i would get from
here that's an exact value
i can evaluate that and that will help
me get rid of these sort of pesky terms
right
so that's good but then when you turn to
the other part of this trigonometric
identity cos of
a plus b you're going to have to not
just subtract you're going to have to
add these angles
so you can see here you run into a
problem right 3 pi and 12
plus 7 pi on 12 10 pi
on 12 that's 5 pi on 6 you can't get an
exact value for this but
surely there are some easier ones that i
can go to okay
so you can do this any way you like but
i'm going to suggest instead of pairing
up those
i'm going to go 3.12 and 9 pi on 12. i
think that's going to be easy to deal
with
and then i'm also going to pair up 7 pi
on 12 with
11 pi on 12. um i want to emphasize
you can do this either way but i think
you'll find
that the numbers are going to be much
more easy on you if you
pair it up this way so for starters
let's get the part that i'm actually
interested in in the end
the pi on 12 and the 5 pi on 12.
let's get it out the front and then
let's see what happens when i pair these
particular angles up i've got cos
of 3 pi on 12 cos
of 9 pi on 12 and then i'm going to have
a cos of what i pair up 7 pi on 12
and 11 pi on 12. all of that
is equal to minus
or negative 1 over 32. let's get
everything over on the
this side so let's parallel okay so like
i said you can pair these up in a
variety of different ways but i want to
make it the easiest
possible all right here we go so i've
got uh
this cosplay on 125.12 out the front i
know that's not going to
change because it's going to
uh i'll leave that over there it's going
to be part of the result
that i'm aiming for right so it's going
to be there in the end
so i'll leave that and then when i have
a look at the next part because of 3.12
cos 9 pi over 12 using this identity
here
i can write it as half outside of
okay let's do the difference so again
i'm going to do a subtraction 9 pi 12
minus
3 pi 12 is 6 pi 12
which is pi on 2 so i'm going to get
that was a really messy bracket
i'm going to get cos pi on 2 out the
front and then when i add them and this
is where it was much more helpful
rather than something awkward like you
know five pound on six which you can do
but
i want something simpler um can you see
that when you do three point twelve plus
nine point twelve when you go to the sum
you get twelve pi on 12 which is just pi
isn't that nice that is a much easier
angle to deal with
then when i go to this uh final one over
here something very similar
happens because um the difference is
going to be 4 pi and 12 we saw that
already it's
pi on 3 and then when you do the sum
you're actually getting you know
something relatively simple you've got
9 plus 11 that's going to be 18.
18 pi on 12 is 3
pi on 2 and all of that is equal
to negative 1 and 32.
we're on the home stretch because we can
finally evaluate some stuff that will
make this
easier i'm going to get my chosen
results out the front here and then what
have i got
i've got a half cos pi and 2 we saw this
earlier this is a root so that's just
going to be
zero cos of pi if i know my graph well
is negative one
and then bringing up the rear here i've
got a half
of cos pi on 3 cos of 60 degrees you
might recognize that as
a half and then cos 3 pi on 2
again just like cos pi and 2 that's a
root so i'm going to say that's
plus 0. and again that is all equal
whoopsie daisy
and that is all equal to negative 1 on
32.
almost there um i one last oh no
not one last time in fact that's a lie
i'm going to copy this cos plan 12
because 5 pi 12 out the front
half times negative 1 is going to be
negative a half then you're getting half
times a half that's positive
a quarter that's all equal to minus 1 on
32
and you can see here in order to get
these all on the right hand side
what's the easiest thing to multiply
it's going to be negative 8.
so i'm getting this is
the second last time that's going to be
negative of negative 8 on
32 and this is truly the last time
uh cosplaying 12 cos 5 pi 12
equals um the negatives cancel 8 over 32
is a quarter as required and you can
breathe
a sigh of relief so what can we learn
from this question well first let's have
a look at part c which we just did and
then we'll look at the overall thing
this question here it's very unassuming
it's very brief but you can see we had
to bring in some fairly major
major conceptual um you know skills you
have to go all the way back to your
understanding of roots and coefficients
in a fairly unusual power power six to
do that
to get to this line and then when we got
to that line um you had another hurdle
to cross which was
you had to use this less common
trigonometric identity
um to be able to reframe this and then
as well you wanted to pair up these
angles in a helpful way
to make your work easier rather than
harder so
that that brings you to the end of the
question and when you look at the
beginning of it right
these parts here are really just leading
to this
result and it's quite bizarre actually
that when you think of cosplaying 12 and
cos 5 pi and 12
if you went to a calculator
and when you went to evaluate these
particular things
um let me just make sure i'm in radians
i am i think that's where it defaults
anyway if you were to put in
cos where's it gone cos of pi
on 12 and then when you were to look at
oopsie daisy cos of 5 pi
on 12. you look at that and you think my
goodness like
what sort of weird decimal rubbish is
going on here
but you can see that if i actually
take these two things together and if i
actually multiply them
to confirm scroll all the way there this
result that i've got here
to me it's quite astonishing that you
can take these very bizarre
results which are in fact i'm just messy
looking absurds
and if you in fact multiply them
together
sure enough whoopsie daisy if you put a
pie in the right spot
you do get a quarter on this marvelously
simple
rational result no sirds to be seen
so hope you found that helpful i know
there is a lot to take in
in this question and that is why it's
scaffolded in this way hopefully one of
the lessons you take out of this
is how important it is to know some
early results like your
binomial coefficients and your
trigonometric identities and your
polynomials as well
because they all cohere very well
together that's one of the things that
will characterize your final exams once
you know everything
we can combine them in challenging and
unusual ways